good morning heck it's Tuesday you know
how there are those videos that are like
so and so answers the web's most
searched questions about them and that's
fine but like how do I know that I can
trust so and so there's a part of me
that wants so and so's like sibling to
answer the most asked questions about so
and so here are the most asked questions
about Hank Green answered by his brother
what does Hank Green do well I don't
know everything he runs complexly on
educational media company that makes
crash course and scishow and eons and
journey to the microcosmos and lots of
other things he also runs dftba.com a
merch company and he runs the awesome
socks Club a sock subscription service
for charity he is the author of two
critically acclaimed and best-selling
novels he's a musician hold on I'm just
going to go to Wikipedia I do this a lot
when I'm trying to uh remember all the
stuff that Hank does okay that was
helpful he's also a podcaster he's huge
on Tick Tock and he won an Emmy for
helping make this adaptation of Pride
and Prejudice called the Lizzie Bennett
Diaries did Hank Green invent 3D glasses
no I forgot that Hank Green and ended
something much more important than 3D
glasses 2D glasses that render
three-dimensional movies in a crisp two
Dimensions this was actually the first
moment when Hank went from being a
person with a lot of ideas to being a
person with a lot of ideas and some
system for making those ideas into
realities he called me one day and he
was like hey uh Catherine and I went to
the movies and she really doesn't like
3D movies because it gives her a
headache I think it'd be fairly
straightforward to make glasses that
turn 3D movies into 2D movies and would
you like to go in with me on this
exciting business venture and I was like
no I was definitely wrong and I learned
my lesson which is never bet against
Hank Green what disease does Hank Green
have Hank has ulcerative colitis he's
lived with it for most of his adult life
now and it's really hard but also he's
doing it how does Hank Green know so
much so neither Hank nor I were
particularly amazing students in school
but when Hank got to college and
especially grad school he got really
passionate about learning and then he
just kept learning he kept researching
and kept trying to understand the world
around him and I think that's how he
knows so much is a mix of research and
having been a passionate learner for so
many decades what does John Green write
about I love it when Hank and I show up
in each other's Google searches I'll
tell you what I don't write about
siblings all right lightning round is
Hank Green still alive yes married yes
vegan I actually don't know related to
John Green yes is Hank Green a professor
no is hankering from Montana yes is Hank
Green in Jurassic Park
I don't think so we were like eight when
it came out does Hank Green have a PhD
no he has a masters does he have a
brother yes does he have a podcast Yes
dear Hank and John also delete this also
scishow tangents does he have a degree
yes does he have a child yes one does he
still run VidCon no oh I forgot about
that Hank has also started many
companies including subable which became
part of patreon and Vidcon which is now
owned by other people he's also started
many companies that became nothing like
he had this great idea you are eletron
that was kind of going to be linktree
before wink tree like a place where all
of your URLs would go and it was
actually a very good idea it was just
like slightly wrongly times but one of
my very favorite things Hank Green
helped found is the project for awesome
and this year between February 17th and
February 19th we'll be having the 16th
project for awesome it's a 48-hour live
stream Extravaganza where we raise money
for charity you can get lots of great
perks for donating and in order for it
all to work we need a matching fund Hank
and I donate to the matching fund every
year so do hundreds of other
Nerdfighters and if you're in a position
to donate 500 or more please join us at
projectforawesome.com
matching Hank you are amazing I'm your
biggest fan and I have been your biggest
fan since you were born you're just
incredible don't be afraid to take it
down a couple notches if you need to
okay because I worry about you sometimes
because I
like you so much all right I'll see you
on Friday